a week ago a court in New York City
threw out a series of climate change
lawsuits that had been filed by the city
against oil companies asking them to pay
for the damage that they helped
contribute to by contributing to climate
change they wanted the oil companies
these multibillion-dollar entities to
pay for the damage they caused right
judge throws out the lawsuits in New
York about a week or two after a judge
in California did the same thing when we
had about 12 to 14 cities in California
suing oil companies because the cities
were having to pay to mitigate climate
change they were having to pay for
things like sea-level rise and increased
hospitalizations due to pollution they
wanted the oil companies who are
partially responsible for this to pay
their fair share and so far these
lawsuits are getting thrown out of court
left and right why in both instances
we're talking about different judges
here the judges said because the issue
of climate change and addressing climate
change that something Congress needs to
do that's not something the court system
needs to do let me tell you something
you know why we don't have lead paint in
this country anymore
yeah it's because Congress enacted
legislation but do you know why they did
because of all the lawsuits against them
do you know why there's warning labels
on cigarettes because Congress passed a
law do you know why Congress passed a
law because of all the lawsuits I mean
the list is endless here right I yes
we're still importing asbestos but there
is a you know national asbestos fund for
the people who are getting mesothelioma
from it there are so many other
instances where these things arise in
the courts brought by trial lawyers to
make things right to protect American
citizens
so for these judges to say that no the
courts can't handle this this is
something that needs to be done through
legislation first and foremost you're
100% wrong because this is how most
major consumer protections have happened
in this country and
have you paid attention to this Congress
do you know what they're doing
because I do and most of us do and the
answer is nothing on the issue of
climate change they're doing nothing
yeah we just got rid of Scott Pruett who
is one of the most anti-environmental
heads of the EPA we've ever had and now
we've got an actual coal lobbyist
sitting in there right now as the acting
head of the EPA Andrew wheeler things
for the environment are getting worse
than ever this administration the
President himself once called climate
change a hoax by the Chinese they're not
going to do anything about it the
majority of people their representative
in this country is a climate change
denier the majority of people in this
country are represented in Congress by
somebody who either thinks that climate
change isn't real or that we shouldn't
do anything about it so yeah the
majority of us we got somebody in
Congress who doesn't think it's a big
deal or that it's even a deal so why why
would these courts tell us that we have
to rely on Congress you know the people
that are bought and paid for by the
fossil fuel industry by the frakkers by
the coal companies that are going
bankrupt left and right but they still
have enough money to give to politicians
none of this makes any sense
we are living in upside-down topsy-turvy
crazy land and these judges who are
supposed to help us and protect us say
no you're gonna have to go deal with
those crazy people up on Capitol Hill if
you want you can follow me on twitter at
Theron Farr Oh in balanced at fair and
balanced I am fair and Cousins sitting
in for David Pakman today and we'll be
right back today's program is sponsored
in part by Blink accom slash Pakman if
you've not already heard about blinka
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudoscience
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a David Pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a 7 day free trial
by going to blink accom slash Pakman if
you're watching on youtube use the link
in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month that's be Li NK is t.com /pa ke ma
n